the secret to making great food is to
ensure you lock in every last ounce of
flavour in that pan and this spicy
sausage rice does exactly that
take these spicy sausages and pierce
that skin because i want all that
delicious spicy sausage meat out of this
casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas
bread onion less acidic than a big white
spanish onion and a lot more flavoursome
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because i want all that fat coming
out the sausages to sort of really help
flavor the onions onions in
and the onions go in first because you
can never rush cooking an onion it's
really important to sort of give them
five to six minutes in the pan so you
can really start to caramelize them
from the out of my pepper
slice around
wasting nothing
i want to see that sort of
little core those pips in the center no
fine diced pepper the rice is going to
be cooking for 20 minutes so i want the
veg to sort of have texture after it's
cooked
peppers in a bit of garlic two nice
cloves
just slap down
off with the shell
garlic in
now i want to turn up the gas get the
pan nice and hot because the minute that
sausage goes in everything cools down
and you'll end up boiling the peppers
and the onions and the garlic so heat up
to maximum and then just make a well
in the center
in
now
start stirring quickly
this is where you get so much more bang
for your buck out of sausages because
the skins off and the real flavor of
that spicy italian sausage is gonna come
through
what's great about this recipe is that
you can use any type of sausage to get
the flavour and the heat you want i've
gone for the spicy italian but it's just
as good with merguez or chorizo
a teaspoon
paprika in give it that really nice
smoky flavor
rice in and we're going to sort of
basically sear the rice we call it in
the kitchen blasting the rice where we
sort of soda the rice for 30 seconds and
it takes on all that flavor
next white wine so the wine sort of
deglazes the pan and washes all that
flavor from the bottom of the pan into
the rice
stock in bring it up to the boil turn it
down and let it simmer
[Music]
double stop to rice
turn that gas down
and let it simmer for 12 to 15 minutes
and just give it the occasional stir
keep an eye on it now get ready to
finish it
slice spring onions diced sweet juicy
tomatoes and roughly chop earthy flat
leaf parsley
sprinkling is in tomatoes in
off with the gas really important
otherwise everything becomes overcooked
flat leaf parsley in
but look
at the volume in that pan now that
is an amazing way to take spicy italian
sausages
to a completely different level
beautiful
[Music]
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off your onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs in a classic way but the
exciting part is actually cook them in
coconut milk and it gives a really nice
new dimension to a sort of soft
rich sumptuous meatball
chop the onion nice and finely keeping
those slices very close together
closer the slices the finer the onions
pat it back down at an angle slice down
and just chop
i want the onions nice and fine because
i want some finesse to these meatballs
the secret of a really good meatball is
the texture
getting that balance right
between the minced beef the bread crumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple cloves of
garlic slice the garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in we'll touch the
salt
and pepper
your mince open it up a little bit
and sort of pat it out salt
and pepper
for me
a good meatball is all about the
the softness the texture of that rich
beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again i've
got some really nice
dried chili flakes i'm gonna season the
onions with the chili flakes chili
flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
i'm gonna add some milk
take your bread crumbs
make a little well three four
tablespoons of milk that makes a sort of
nice
slightly doughy texture
but it lightens the texture of the
meatball
place that
in
add your onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small the problem
with making them too small is the fact
that they dry out quickly
just the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
really nice tight squeeze that stops it
from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time
give the pan a little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom get that pan nice and hot a touch
of olive oil in there
place them
at the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a pallet knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball
we're going to add some heat coriander
seeds
slightly spicy and peppery just to give
a really nice flavor to the coconut milk
in next some cardamom seeds three or
four onto the board knife on
in a little touch of turmeric into the
center of the pan that's gonna give it a
really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch
cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier
a couple of dried chilies let them
infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of
beat it down that starts to release all
that lovely sort of fragrance like
someone's just
let off the most amazing
fragrant air freshener in the lemongrass
and finally some fresh ginger
just peel
and slice nice and thinly
time now
to turn them over
and let the other half a wonderful
flavor
chicken stock
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
i want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the top of the meatball
coconut milk in and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant
light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
nice soft texture of the meatball for
that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth just gonna cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
then simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger this should
be slightly pliable but
slightly springy gas off i'm gonna
finish it off with something light and
fresh zest of lime but i want the zest
on top of the meatball
so i'll cut through that richness
and then finally
squeeze the fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice
zesty amazing taste
stirring the juice
i've got that kick and that
vibrant taste
now
the exciting part
when you come to serve it
be generous with that coconut broth
tilt the pan
get a good couple of ladles of the broth
in
meatballs
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball
and bringing it into the 21st century
and they're just as good cooked from
frozen as well
[Music]
take a sieve
when you think of short crust pastry
it's sort of
semi-flaky but it's rich buttery
start by sipping 200 grams of plain
flour into a mixing bowl
large pinch
of salt
200 grams of unsalted butter
bring the butter up to room temperature
if you let the butter become too soft
and the flour so it doesn't absorb it in
with your fingers rub together first
now the secret is
grab big handfuls and squeeze the butter
into the flour
so look what's happened literally in 30
seconds i've got that nice
crumbly
texture
now a couple of tablespoons
of water nothing worse when the pastry
is so wet you can't bring it together it
needs to shape like a nice rich cookie
dough it's just a touch to dry
so
one more
tablespoon of water
[Music]
and there you go it's coming nicely
now
that's what i want
a nice sort of
firm ball of pastry
onto the board
i'm going to use these
one of the strongest parts of the body
pull towards you and push back down use
those wrists
to really
knead it
together
so just that nice sort of smooth texture
now
wrap it in cling film
set that in the fridge for 20 minutes
really important that you let the
shortcuts pastry relax
[Music]
now to make the quiche you can use just
an ordinary flan dish but i love making
them in many frying pans which give them
an extra rustic charm
brush with oil to stop the pastry from
sticking
once the pastry is at room temperature
roll it out to a nice even thickness
place it in the center of your little
pan
turn it in don't use your fingers
because what we don't want is any holes
in this just get a little bit of
dough because that sort of acts like a
little sort of mallet
flattens it out nicely
i'm building a sort of
extra lip because that way i can get the
filling at those absolute maximum levels
we're going to cook them blind first
to blind bake simply means to pre-cook
your pastry before adding the filling
this ensures you'll have a fantastic
crisp pastry
add a sheet of foil or baking paper and
weigh it down
you can use rice pulses or ceramic
baking stones
just make sure you keep them for the
next time
into the oven 200 degrees for 10 minutes
now for the filling
i'll do a classic quiche bacon and leeks
this is a amazing cured pancetta
pancetta is an italian cured meat made
from belly pork seasoning with things
like juniper nutmeg fennel a great
substitute is unsmoked bacon
as the pancetta gets lovely and crispy
finely sliced leeks and add
oh
leek some bacon nice
really important to cook those leeks
down
exactly what i want those leaks are
almost sort of caramelized slightly
crispy the flavor's amazing and just
drain them off so any excess fat gets
drained couple of tablespoons of cream
it gives it
it's really nice of richness
i want two-thirds garnish i.e bacon and
leeks in my quiche and one-third of the
savory custard
a touch of salt
a touch of pepper
and i grate some gruyere cheese
that makes a really nice sort of creamy
less of an eggy quiche take my amazing
crispy pancetta and leeks in
give that a good mix
need one more little thing some
freshness
flat
leaf parsley
incredible
really important just to taste
the mixture
with the quiche filling ready next
finish off the pastry
[Music]
remove the fall and weight and return to
the oven to get it lovely and golden all
over
[Music]
now
when we fill them give that a really
good mix up
[Music]
beautiful
grate over some more cheese which will
bubble up and melt beautifully and then
into the oven
bake your quiche for 15 to 20 minutes
[Music]
incredible
it's got that nice sort of cheese and
toast smell from the top it's sort of
baked but the secret of any good quiche
is in the short crust because that's the
hero
[Music]
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that's
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down
through the center turn it over
and again into quarters
so you've got all that opening up and
then just rinse the top of that to get
rid of any potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add all that leek
into those mushrooms
beautiful
[Music]
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you can left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic nice and crispy
now we're gonna add a touch of chicken
stock in there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken stock would reduce down by half
and it's almost delays at the bottom of
the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center
it's ready
turn the sauce down
and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just gonna turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now
pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple they can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
you